el segundo ejército del mundo contra uno
que no figura ni siquiera entre los 20
primeros después de ocho días de
invasión rusa en ucrania la devastación
es ejemplo claro de esa desigualdad y
según reconoce vladimir putin el inicio
de una victoria y
queridos camaradas quiero decirles que
la operación militar especial está
marchando estrictamente de acuerdo a la
agenda de acuerdo al plan todos los
objetivos han sido exitosamente
alcanzados spears no 36 del otro lado su
par ucraniano se muestra abierto un
diálogo directo que ponga fin al horror
esto te jugoso schattmann que quiere de
nosotros váyase de nuestra tierra no se
quiere ir ahora siéntese conmigo en la
mesa de negociación estoy disponible
siéntese conmigo pero no a 30 metros
como reciba macrón ya scioli ya los
otros
macro un sol de mentalidad elegante
empremar pero al mismo tiempo se lens
que clama por ayudas que le permitan
desplegar una defensa más efectiva
dirección vendemos tras aprobar si no
pueden introducir una zona de exclusión
aérea ahora díganos cuando si no pueden
decir ahora los ucranianos cuando le
introducirán que más necesitan digan
cuánta gente debe morir
necesitamos aviones según entiendo este
tema está siendo discutido en polonia y
eeuu ahora ni a tecos me pulse y ys
productions touch según el portal
especializado poder de fuego global el
de ucrania apareció en el puesto 22
entre los ejércitos más poderosos del
mundo mientras que el de rusia es el
segundo su presupuesto militar es menos
del 10 por ciento de los 154 mil
millones de dólares que rusia destina a
la defensa las tropas armadas un cuarto
las aeronaves militares
318 contra cuatro mil 173 de rusia los
tanques apenas una fracción y el poder
naval un ínfimo 0,5 por ciento desde su
vecino con un millón de refugiados y
buena parte del país reducido a
escombros la negociación puede ser la
única puerta que le quede a ucrania